I have an unopened bottle of liquid multimins called aqueous multiflus from biotics research.
There is no folic acid or folated and is it okay to take? I know they are higher
and brand but just wanted to check. So I'm familiar with that product but I would say no,
I mean that has copper in it, it has cyanokabolamine in it. I don't think it's a great supplement.
So I don't think it's a great supplement for anybody. I don't, I don't, you know again,
a lot of these companies, we sell a lot of biotics research and I think a lot of their products are
really, really good but I do think that sometimes, you know, there isn't any supplement company
that I think all their products are good. I'll just tell you that right now.
It makes me scratch my head like why in the world are you selling this with this in it? You know,
sometimes it's because that's an older supplement. It might have been introduced in
the 90s or something when the knowledge was more limited and they have a lot of doctors
that still buy it so they keep selling it. And then sometimes supplement companies have
they hire a doctor to be their, you know, their chief of staff that is going to help with
formulations that isn't really good. And then they start introducing products that, why are you
introducing that? Because they're kind of fan type product products and they're good companies
like Zymanchid and Orthomolecular and designs for health and standard process. I mean, good to say
standard process took forever. They would, you know, they would fight with the whole glue to
90, 95% of their supplements have gluten in them. And they just would not. They still haven't
changed. Now they have some with their lie that are gluten free, but they wouldn't change because
they just wouldn't change with the times. So it's, yeah, it's difficult so that, you know, you have to
cherry pick, you know, even good companies don't necessarily all have good supplements. I mean,
cyanokabolid. Why in the world do you have a product with cyanokabolid in it? That makes
absolutely no sense. In the way the other minerals in this product are, are bound is just, it's not
a natural product. So I would not use that product, sorry.